tonight I'm going to talk about the
cinematography on big hero six along
with the rendering in some of the
research we did so one of the early
mandates early in the development of the
film was as has been talked about
there's one this is going to be a huge
world it was gonna be this kind of
unseen scale we just haven't seen an
animated movie and also like Don was
talking about earlier it was going to be
the city San fransokyo which was kind of
this mashup of San Francisco and Tokyo
which is Michael said is something where
you know people really are familiar with
you know what those places look like and
what the light is is like and so we
wanted to be able to do really
believable light simulations for those
worlds as well and so what we did was we
developed our own render to help solve
this problem this started developing as
a big hero 6 was developing around the
same time and it solved both these
problems it could do physical lights and
simulations it was a global illumination
render that can do full ray tracing but
also like Kyle was talking about it
could handle kind of this unseen scale
which I'll talk a little bit about how
it did that what we call that is
streaming geometry and what that is is
in a ray tracer you have a camera here
and that camera fires out array it
actually fires a lot of rays out but if
I was out array and it hits something in
the scene and it samples samples that
and then that goes off and shoots array
and hits a light and and that's how we
we'd know that that rock has been
colored by that light and then we can
extend that and it it bounces more and
we call that one bounce and then you go
to this and you extend that and you can
see it gets really complicated quick in
fact you know generally a ray tracer out
there you need to have the whole
environment loaded at a single time with
Hyperion there's this idea of streaming
geometry where it bundles up rays that
are going in a similar direction and
then it figures out what geometry it's
going
hit it does a test for that and then it
only loads up that given geometry which
you can see represented here in the
color and what that lets us do is load
up much smaller chunks of the geometry
at a given time as opposed to having to
have everything loaded at at once and
then we could have much more complexity
and sophistication to any part of that
environment at one given time and that's
how we were able to achieve what Kyle
was talking about this kind of kind of
almost infinite amount of data we could
put into our cities at one given time
like I said we were developing this
really early on with big hero six it was
kind of a risky thing and so we are
encouraging all our artists to to grab
Hyperion I was getting develop and try
and test it see what we can do with it
give us feedback and how it's working
this is an image that one of our look
artists Alex Alvarado did the image on
the left is the self-portrait that he
did in Hyperion and the image on the
right is a character he did of his
supervisors we have fun dizzy so we can
go the next slide and so around that
same time this is this is about a year
you know Hyperion is really early on and
we wanted to kind of go really back to
kind of simplicity kind of like Zack was
talking about spheres with the the
animation we needed to do something
similar with the lighting so we we got a
bunch of spheres they're made up of a
different bunch of different materials
wood marble glass and and actually we've
got a ping-pong ball there's as well and
we have an lighting studio at Disney
Animation where we can we have a full
set of physical lights and cameras and
we can do tests and try different things
out and research so here we have the
photo reference that we took on the
screen left and then the Hyperion
recreation on the screen right you can
see how how close and and kind of
actually excited we were to see how well
things were working early on I should
mention here if you notice the ping-pong
ball on the screen left and the shadow
poking in and it has that really kind of
luminous fill
of the ping-pong ball lighting up that
shadow that wasn't actually what we got
our first tryout actually we got with
something more like this where you can
see you know I was talking about letting
the light rays bounce around once we get
to the lower screen left there where it
kind of looks like the ping-pong ball
looks like a kind of dirty kind of
plastic ball that's letting the buy
light bounce around one time and that's
typically what we were doing and a lot
of the industry does is you can really
only afford to let the light simulate
one bounce maybe two bounces what we
found is we needed to let D'Lite bounce
around ten times which was a little
scary because no one had had let things
go that much but we had to do it because
as you can see our main character baymax
here is made of on all much like that
ping-pong ball and as Donna was talking
about you know he needs to be really
appealing
he needs to be likable and as he
described huggable and as you see in the
screen left here bottom image he has a
dirty feeling if you just let the light
simulation go one bounce so we actually
had to let it go 10 bounces any shot
with baymax had 10 bounces of light
simulated and the environment here has
about 5 to 6 bounces you can actually
see that the difference not only in
baymax but the richness of the
environment when you let the light
bounce around and you get that warm
sunlight bouncing around it really added
to our imagery every shot in the movie
had at least five to six bounces of
light simulated and any shot with baymax
was 10